joining me today is an evolutionary
psychologist and author and associate
professor at the University of New
Mexico Jeffrey Miller welcome to the
Rubin report Dave great to be here good
to be with you my friend
you know I realized I've had
evolutionary biologists on the show I've
had Brett Weinstein and Richard Dawkins
I've had psychologists on the show
Jordan Peterson I've never had an
evolutionary psychologist never know
very many of us yeah how many how many
are there we're almost extinct yeah the
big international conference we get
maybe 300 people versus like a big
neuroscience conference we'll be 30,000
that's got to be a tough crowd it's a
tough crowd
we get a lot of flack from all
directions but I would I wouldn't want
to do anything else it's an it's an
awesome field and I can't imagine
anything more fun than studying human
nature for a living yeah and you're
studying and have written about so many
incredible topics I normally I always I
pride myself on the fact that I usually
don't have to look at my notes when
interviewing somebody but you've been so
many things that every now and again I
am gonna be glancing down because I
don't want to miss anything here but
usually the way I like to start these is
just finding out a little bit of
someone's history what sort of brought
them to the place of expertise that gets
them in that chair so just tell me a
little bit about you know growing up
education that sort of thing what made
you interested in all this I was born
and raised in Cincinnati Ohio went to
undergrad at Columbia University I
studied psychology and biology and just
anything that grabbed my interest so I
kind of started out in neuroscience and
I thought the brain's fascinating and
then I kind of drifted into cognitive
psychology which is studying human
learning and memory and perception and
how we categorize stuff and then I got
really bored with that but I thought I
don't I don't know a go a go pH do a PhD
in that anyway so I went to Stanford
started doing cognitive psychology but
when I was there I met these two
brilliant postdocs who are working with
my adviser leda cosmides and john tooby
who had just come from
Harvard and they basically invented the
field of evolutionary psychology right
there at Stanford in front of my nose
hmm from the ground up
and they were like we're going to take
evolutionary biology anthropology
cognitive psychology merge them all
together and make this new science of
human nature
yeah so let's slow down for a second so
how what does that synthesis look like
what does that even mean when they're
yeah talking about this how do you take
these things that are thought of as
their own institutions and you know put
them into one box it's basically like
the key insight is if you want to
understand human nature whether it's
anything human sexuality or emotions or
how we relate to other people or other
groups you can always ask the question
where did we come from
what challenges that our ancestors faced
in terms of surviving and reproducing
and raising kids and what exact
structure did those challenges have like
what was ancestral life like we don't
know every every detail but we do know a
lot from anthropologists who studied
hunter-gatherers we know a lot from
primatologists who have studied chimps
and bonobos and and and gorillas and the
rank towns and you can kind of
triangulate on a picture of prehistoric
life and figure out yeah like why do we
fear certain things snakes and spiders
and bears and whatever well it's because
there were certain selection pressures
like if you don't fear those things you
die why do we look for certain things in
mates when we're choosing sexual
partners well if you don't look for
those things then you have bad
relationships and bad kids etc so it's a
way of looking at the past to inform our
understanding of the present and that's
not what most of psychology does so it's
quite a novel kind of approach but I
think we've got we've got an enormous
leverage out of it was there pushback
from people within each discipline going
well we've got all the answers right
here why do we want to put these things
together because I would imagine there's
always a certainty inherently
competition amongst all of these
different disciplines
yeah the evolutionary biologists kind of
hate it because
to be my next question since I know
they're a couple of those guys they're
happy to go here's how other animals
evolve they're happy to go here's how
the human body evolved here's how the
human immune system evolved but once you
get above the neck then they're like
you're just gonna make trouble for us
and biology because that's where things
get politically controversial is when
you start explaining human behavior or
individual differences or sex
differences or human emotions with stuff
like that so the biologists don't like
it the anthropologists had a lot of the
same issues like we've spent the last
century trying to get anthropology kind
of a way from biology in a way so please
don't drag us kicking and screaming back
into that yeah that swamp of controversy
but we just got kind of plowed ahead and
and I think it's been a big success
story and in the sciences in the last 30
years so what were the things that were
intriguing to you that had sort of bored
you from the other I think the the fact
that sexuality is central to
evolutionary biology and evolutionary
psychology you know it's how how we got
our genes and the next generation is
choosing mates and having babies and
raising raising kids and if you ignore
that you ignore I think one of the core
driving forces in human nature and human
culture now most of psychology kind of
ignores mate choice and sexuality and
reproduction except insofar as it's kind
of like seen as politically relevant so
like you'll get a little bit on well
there's sexual discrimination against
certain kind of groups which is
important to address like gay and
lesbian rights and and so forth but they
don't really see it as central to who we
are into what motivates us so do you see
it as the real pillar of what's
motivating us like if we were sort of
looking at this in action
circles I think it depends where you're
at in life I think for young single
people what we call mating effort like
the attempt to attract other people
whatever is such orientation that drives
an awful lot of behavior how you dress
what ideas you adopt why you bother to
learn things why you bother to get
credentials I think a lot of that is
driven by mating effort but then if you
settle down and you're in a long-term
monogamous relationship you don't kind
of need to do that stuff but that's
exactly what really though that's where
people let themselves go right they
don't stay in shape they dress more
sloppily they kind of don't bother
reading like serious nonfiction anymore
why because a lot of that sort of
creative display has already
accomplished its its purpose so in that
way that's not in real conflict with
evolutionary biology right because you
want to look your best to get the best
media that's what in that way you guys
are on the same track so where does that
where does that deviate well so when
biologists talk about courtship displays
and here's the bowerbird building its
power and we talked about like
ideological displays and there's people
showing off like their virtues for
virtue signaling the biologists know
exactly what we're talking about and we
know exactly what they're talking about
it's just often they don't want to get
in the trouble that that follows if they
kind of make these analogies too clearly
have you had any of these conversations
with Brett Weinstein not directly yeah
no I think I'm gonna have to facilitate
that one probably those or there'll be a
lot of fun yeah yeah I'll do that for
sure
so it's interesting okay so let's let's
focus on the sexuality parties for a
little bit because it seems like so many
things that we used to be able to talk
about we suddenly can't talk about or
that academics are self-selecting out of
and things of that nature now I said to
you right before we started you're one
of the few people I see our Twitter I'm
like oh you guys guess what Twitter is
because you put on some smart stuff
you're kind of funny on there at the
right time you know when to go with
snark and all of those things
and that to me seems the only way that
you would be able to have any of these
conversations online I think social
media is actually really good for
addressing some of these very tricky
issues like human sexuality and how it's
playing out in the modern world as long
as you do with humor and self
deprecation and a little bit of
absurdity which is what I try to do in
my Twitter game right because if you
approach it like well here's the next
paper on like sex differences or the
next paper on how courtship works or Oh
awesome a new virtue signaling paper
people will quickly tune out and the
lost and often think well you're just
kind of being doctrinaire here but the
thing you quickly realize if you study
evolution at all is evolution is a very
weird process that often produces
completely absurd results right you
watch any David Attenborough Natural
History you know documentary and it's
like these animals are insane what
they're doing is crazy and humans are no
different yeah and if you don't have a
sense of that absurdity then it's very
easy to get terribly terribly serious
and censorious and ideological and that
really catalyzed a lot doesn't is going
on that doesn't really help anybody yeah
all right so let's let's pause on
sexuality for a second I don't want to
get off that topic so to speak but let's
just do the two-minute Twitter portion
of the show which is is there a
evolutionary explanation to the way
we're behaving with each other is there
a psychological explanation to the way
we act one way on this medium and
another way on another medium and and
how that has evolved because of the age
of communication it's a great question
and I think honestly social media
blindsided everybody I don't know
anybody in the 90s in psychology or any
behavioral science who was going here's
what the internet is going to turn into
right it'll become this massive global
system of very rapid fire interact
snarky virtue signaling that drives
everyone nuts and yet we can't give it
up yeah I know villain k dick probably
would not but maybe nobody else yeah
okay dick maybe William Gibson a few
other folks kind of add the insight but
honestly nobody was deriving kind of
from first principles well we are a
social primate and we love to gossip and
we love to show off you know our virtues
and our intelligence to each other and
therefore obviously there will be this
thing called Facebook and Twitter and
whatever and it will play out in this
way and moreover it will revolutionize
politics or culture in some way
no nobody thought that so we can come up
with post hoc reasons why that might
have played out that way but I want to
only do that with a very high degree of
humility like I don't know I don't it
now that we're here you can kind of a
little bit make sense of it that well
it's almost like you can see the
evolution um Twitter you know domain
where you now see people I'd like to
include myself of that where they're
trying to clean it up a little bit it's
like we all did this unknown thing of
snark that everyone was trying to
destroy each other and one-up each other
and you signal about the things we care
about all that
and it's like now I'm seeing a growing
group of people that are like whoa how
do we deal with reality in the confines
of social media but when maturely and
honestly and without just wrecking
everything and that almost strikes me as
an evolutionary function and it's
evolution is happening so fast and on
such a huge scale I mean who could have
predicted that like the more amateurish
looking a visual mean is a better it
would spread that's completely bizarre
or the fact that I can get more
engagement if I do a really surreal poll
on Twitter about something where all
four categories are just completely
insane
like people are more into that right
than they are like even my snarky
comment about political issue X or Y so
what does that tell you about the
psychological state of how we interact
with these things like the mean one's
really interesting it's not the slate I
produced quick thing you know really
sharp looking images that go viral it's
you know a frog on a black-and-white
idiotic thing or a crudely drawn this or
that tree or whatever like there's
something really there today about how
we react to images this there's also
something kind of charming about the
artlessness and amateurish quality it's
almost like if I'm kind of fascinated by
stand-up comedy and the stand-up
comedians who are overly slick are never
that funny and the ones who are a little
bit shambolic like stephen wright back
in the 80s hilarious and he looks he
looks like he's always on the edge of
complete failure or a psychotic break
and yet that's what makes it work or I
guess Seinfeld's you know in the 90s the
show was also kind of had this art less
quality yeah alright so let's do that so
that's already now okay it's getting
harder and harder to talk about these
things there's a set of people that
think we're all exactly the same and
then at the same time they're obsessed
with all of our differences I mean this
is what seemingly is the most potent
idea of the day right now what are what
are the things that you're thinking
about in the realm of sexuality right
now that are intriguing I'm thinking I'm
especially concerned about the fact that
nobody seems to know what a successful
long-term relationship is seriously
going to look like in the early to mid
21st century that we don't really have a
script for that we've kind of inherited
you know the script of monogamous
lifelong marriage but nobody really
believes that that is going to kind of
solve all of our problems and people
don't enter into that very early in life
they spend their teens and 20s doing
casual dating what is that like nobody
quite understands what the
the rules where the ethics of that are
and that at a certain point you kind of
get tired of that and you find a partner
and you kind of settle down and go okay
we're going to buy into the wedding
industry now and do the wedding thing
and the ring bottle but they're all
these subcultures in America and around
the world that are exploring all
different aspects sexuality and kind of
how to incorporate new insights into
relationships things like BDSM or kink
or polyamory and open relationships or
the whole red pill manosphere subculture
and then on the other side of those what
does that have to do with sexuality well
it's a certain way of men and women
interacting right the sort of red pill
vision of male-female dynamics is that
there's a really deep sexual polarity
masculine and feminine and if you don't
understand that polarity your
relationships if they're heterosexual
are gonna fail and burn out and not be
satisfying to either person so there's
much subcultures they're all exploring
different parts of human nature human
sexuality different possible ways to run
a relationship and I think they all have
valuable lessons that we can kind of
learn and incorporate like even if
you're vanilla and monogamous and
straight and you you don't believe all
the the crazy manosphere stuff there's
still important lessons there and that's
kind of my interest now is sort of going
around and and being eclectic and
gathering those up and figuring out
which of those might be useful do people
stay in those scenes for a lifetime so I
you know I could see worse where
somebody you'd be in a whatever your
thing is I'm not passing judgment on
anything whatever your thing is you do
it for a while and then eventually I
guess it sort of is the men you sort of
get tired of it so you move on to
something more traditionally is that
just part of our psychology like nothing
kind of lasts forever some people do
that certainly there's
there's a life profile a kind of
openness and experimentation where you
you try a bunch of stuff in your teens
and 20s and a lot of it deviates
markedly from the traditional culture
you you grow up in and a lot of that
hurts and it doesn't work and it's
heartbreaking and then you a lot of
people kind of drift back into the
mainstream on the other hand you got
people who marry young and they try the
the standard vanilla monogamy thing into
their 30s 40s 50s and then go this is
not working I need something different
better more open whatever and I think it
can go either way
you know the psychological research on
all these subcultures is lacking we
don't know even which lasts longer a
monogamous relationship or an open
relationship everybody don't we don't we
don't know there's not good data on that
there's lots of anecdotes there's
examples on both sides but I think it's
almost scientific misconduct not to ask
those questions and instead to ask like
let's do you know study on which
alcoholism treatment works let's do the
5,000th study on that before we do the
first study on what kind of
relationships last longest so basically
because you think if we could address
some of those issues first
perhaps the studies that we're focusing
on related to out as well Elizabeth yeah
relationship satisfaction is really
really important to people but it's one
of the the things that's it's not
entirely taboo to study it but it's
pretty hard to get federal research
funding to look at something that's kind
of a cornerstone of American well-being
so when that New York Times article came
out about Jordan Peterson and they said
he was for enforced monogamy mmm-hmm
which in effect just means marriage and
if you used a couple times in the times
before it just to me marriage but yeah
when everyone thought that man he wanted
me in Chains to be you know dragged
around by their husbands the the
argument that people that are for
forced monogamy your marriage basically
make is that this is the best way to
build a sort of functioning healthy
society and that you can reproduce and
have other generations and all of those
things you just think we don't have
enough information basically or enough
right well enough study on the
information to know if that really is
the best way to build a human society
right we don't know if there's there's
good reasons to think that monogamous
marriage has been important in every
major civilization like it's kind of the
most common way to arrange pair bonding
and I'm sure
Jordan Peterson has read the same
articles I've assigned even in my
polyamory class that's about here are
the benefits of monogamous marriage and
there are many benefits of it
the question is once you have
contraception once you have safer sex
and STI testing once you have paternity
testing once you have a lot of other
technologies right they can solve some
of the same issues that monogamy used to
solve then what is monogamy still
optimal probably is for a lot of people
probably as for love you how much of it
do you think just comes down to how
you're wired I think there's a lot of
that some people are just wired to go
and I just want to pair bond
I want my mate and I want to keep it
simple and that's good enough for me and
I will get a lot of companion at love
and attachment and it'll last a long
time a lot of people are very happy with
that and that's great but a lot of
people either want more sexual novelty
and variety or they have a higher
tolerance for sexual jealousy or they
just kind of get bored in long-term
relationships and I think those people
should not be prescribing like rampant
polyamory for the monogamists but the
monogamous shouldn't necessarily be
prescribing like our way is only way for
everybody else so I wonder how this is
all related to the gay community because
I don't know dare I mentioned the name
Milo but when
Mylo on my show years ago really before
he was Milan so to speak
we got it we had about a half-hour chat
on this where me is the married gay
liberal and him as the unmarried gay
conservative he's already sort of a flip
on things yeah
his argument was that he wasn't really
for gay marriage because he felt that by
being the outsider the gays have come up
with art and creativity and music and
comedy and all of those that incredible
like just Gestalt of it all that made
this incredible community like a diverse
community in the right sense of
diversity yeah and my argument was well
you've got to at least give people the
opportunity to be equal under the law so
that they at least have a choice I'm not
denying that the gay community has come
up with all sorts of incredible stuff
yeah but like you got to make them equal
and then let them go either way on that
okay yeah do you think there is
legitimacy to that and do you have you
done or have you seen any Studies on
what the effects of the marriage on the
gay community have been I haven't seen a
whole lot but I guess Miley too soon I
mean my understanding and some of this
comes from dan dan Savage right is that
a lot of gay couples have a kind of
monogamous relationship where it's like
we're pair bonded we love each other but
there's also a negotiated agreement that
we can have outside lovers once in a
while under certain conditions that we
kind of mutually agree to see it's funny
I hear that all the time I don't know
advocating couples that I know that are
married or you know really yeah together
I don't know ones that are like that or
at least that I know that they are like
okay but I know that this is a something
that's tossed out there yeah so we can
go with this Bert so but I'm sure
there's variety and I'm sure that
there's also kind of social assortment
all right
so that the more monogamist gay lesbian
couples will kind of be more comfortable
with each other and they might know
those crazy monogamous folks down the
road right or you just out of your
friends that well I mean yeah and
honestly it's not that different from
like the way you
and heterosexual relationships work in a
lot of Europe were a lot of those who
tacitly monogamish and there's a sort of
understanding that monogamy doesn't
necessarily mean sexual exclusivity for
either partner America is extremely
puritanical and kind of rigid about that
and we think anything that happens
outside the pair-bond is almost by
definition unethical and there is
research on a sort of anti polyamory
stigma where people actually are more
prejudiced against people in open
relationships than they are against
almost any other group in terms of
orientation or race or religion or
anything that might be gradually
changing but I think it's a it's a huge
social problem especially among Gen Z
and younger Millennials
[Music]